nouveau smartphone de Samsung qui vient
de sortir c'est le A34 5G on a ici un
grand écran 6,6 pouces et du Super
AMOLED qui va jusqu'à 1000 litres petite
particularité c'est sa caméra qui est
planqué ici dans cette petite encoche
globalement il est élégant et ça j'aime
bien autour ici sur un processeur milieu
de gamme c'est le médiathèque d'emmène
City 100080 qui conviendra bien pour
faire tourner plein de jeux du Play
Store on a une grosse batterie de 5000
milliampères heure de la recharge rapide
25 watts on va retrouver 3 capteurs
photos à l'arrière un premier grand
angle de 48 mégapixels qui va être
stabilisé un petit peu ça c'est bien un
ultra grand angle de 8 mégapixels et une
caméra macro de 2 mégapixels les photos
grand angle sont honnêtes et fonctionne
bien
ultra grand-angle est un peu moins bien
et
je trouve assuré et sans
particulièrement de piquer la caméra de
selfie s'en sort plutôt pas mal avec un
rendu que je trouve très honnête un
smartphone qui résistant à l'eau et à la
poussière avec une certification
IP67 et un verre Corning Gorillaz 5 et
qui est dispo tarif de 39
9 et 469 € version 8 256 dites-moi ce
que vous pensez vous de ce Galaxy A34 5G
marquez moi ça bien évidemment dans les
commentaires